you
[Music]
you
welcome everybody I was going to do a
stream to talk about the Iran downing a
plane and I am going to get to that but
also Donald Trump is holding one of
these absolutely unhinged Magga rallies
I've heard that he is particularly
unhinged in this one so let's take a
listen to it welcome everybody we've got
a lot of different things to discuss and
we will get to them but I don't want to
miss a second of this idiocy this being
build I guess is the first something
rally of some kind who even knows at
this point in time but let's take a
listen to what Donald Trump is saying
this is an Ohio I immediately cancel the
Obama administration's job-killing
catastrophe which would have dealt a
death blow to the United States auto
industry the trans-pacific partnership
it was a disaster that was going to be
worse than after NAFTA I always say the
world worse deal I think that would have
been worse it would have taken the car
industry would have taken many of your
industries that was a set up for the
United States to get fleeced the u.s.
MCA will save the American auto industry
create over 100,000 new auto jobs and
our factories will not be closing and
moving to other faraway lands we'll keep
them right here of that zone
none of this stuff is true at what point
do the same tired talking points no
longer work I guess on his audience they
keep working including tariffs on three
hundred and seventy billion dollars
worth of Chinese made Goods bringing
billions and millions of dollars into
our treasury and I gave some of that
money because they were targeted to our
farmers and our farmers did just fine
and now that's very very much untrue
[Applause]
wait so the farmers are fine or the
farmers are okay suffering he's already
contradicted himself new report from
Trump's own feds says 100% of the
tariffs have been borne by Americans I
don't know why the volume just went down
I've got it next
than I do back to life jsw steel is
investing 500 million dollars in Mingo
junction Republic Steel is reopening
Lorraine mill that they idled in 2016
Charter Steel is building a 150 million
dollars
I know it's Ohio but they're supposed to
shuffle in a black guy right here it's
not supposed to be you know you're looks
like a cornbread white boy all tall the
market steel companies are currently
making thirteen billion dollars worth of
new investments all across our nation
this guy knows about economics right
here we are finally
rebuilding our nation we are finally
putting America first there it is again
[Applause]
but while we are creating jobs and
killing terrorists the Washington
Democrats are wasting America's time
with demented hoaxes and crazy witch
hunts this is actually pretty funny
most guys would have been in the corner
with their thumb in their mouth saying
mommy mommy take me home he's a bad
people the Democrat politicians were
fighting today are the same ones who
took a sledgehammer to Ohio jobs and
factories they destroyed your factories
they destroyed your jobs now that was
you but they're losing and we're winning
and America's comeback continues full
speed what list of drugs do you guys
think Trump is on right now or coming
down from politicians or thoroughly
betrayed the American people then the
issue of illegal immigration far left
radical politician support deadly
sanctuary cities demonstrating their
contempt scorn and disdain for everyday
Americans and the American families
these jurisdictions release state
jurisdictions to defense the consensus
there's one particular thing I kind of
did it there where 20
seems to be having a problem where his
tongue kind of but gets in the way of
his of his lips it's hard to describe
I'm gonna be watching for it attempting
to rape a 14 year old girl then raping
and murdering a 60 year old woman then
shooting another this guy finds this
story super funny
police came we love our police and they
were able to apprehend this terrible
criminal
what's this kid's future like we're
allowed to infiltrate the country you
know I called them animals and Nancy
Pelosi said take a look at what's
happening to her district her district
is one of the most disgusting dirtiest
it used to be one of the best in the
that's blatant racism I mean is this
drug needles all over the place the
homeless that they're not taking care of
tents down major thoroughfares what
happened to San Francisco and in
particular her district as she lives in
this beautiful house right but they
terrorized this can only work in front
of like the absolute dumbest crowd I've
got I'm saying a whole bunch of
questions coming in clearly people have
a lot of a lot on their mind so we'll
continue to check in on this but I do
want to answer some of the things that
are coming in and Dhiru checking in from
Australia says hey David lots of
conservative commentary about the last
40 years of Iranian history can you
remind us about 1953 and any relevance
it might have to the current
relationship yeah we're actually going
to talk about this on tomorrow's show
listen past relationships are relevant
but they just want to excuse Trump's
behavior and defend it and it's just
it's falling flat also via super chat a
lot of people saying Trump is on benzos
which is interesting Tony is ou asks if
I believe Trump if I think Trump even
believes anything he says I do think so
I think Trump is I think there's a
malignancy in Trump does Donald Trump
does believe it also Andrew Dwyer says
the bottom kid has a future at the
Heritage Foundation now well you know
that that could be a good job let's not
let's not make fun of kids waiting to
fade said what exactly are Democrats
supposed to have done to ruin farms yeah
Trump knows he's ruined the farms and
he's of course just insisting that it's
actually Democrats that ever ruined the
farms it doesn't make any sense
over on Twitch and then we'll go back to
this
say he with their twitch Prime
subscription says hey David do you think
the Iran situation was successfully
de-escalated or is it just the beginning
I think that this is a temporary
temporary de-escalation but I do think
that if things don't improve for Trump
he's going to be very interested in
getting back to action there they're a
protester now I don't know you know what
if I had to wait three days I think I
like your seat better okay I like your
seat belt
but Democrats stand for crime yeah again
these these talking points really only
work on very very ignorant people
Democrat Democrats are the party of
crime they go around wanting more crime
a thanks to Shu 322 for signing up with
twitch prime as well as solely 95 for
signing up with twitch Prime folks
asking about phone calls phone calls or
maybe I don't do we know how long I mean
this is not like Fidel Castro right this
is not going to go for hours I take it
it's been going on pen spoke looks like
Trump's been on for Wow Trump's been on
an hour and seven minutes already yeah I
would consider taking some phone calls
we do have one new member oh dear
how am I going to pronounce this
Danushka Jaya tsingy I hope I pronounced
that correctly we do have one new member
if if we do get 15 I will open up the
phone lines for a little bit if people
are interested in that but a lot of
concerns about this this Donald Trump
rally and then I do also have the Justin
Trudeau video I want to talk about the
plane but people were texting me saying
Trump is extra wacked
today so I do want to keep listening
here and there
these people are going to America bomb
there I will not use names because I'll
be accused of something about what but
from Honduras Guatemala El Salvador we
have only in Ohio Cabana who is the man
that did that book who is that so anyway
but Wow Honduras Guatemala they have
like I don't know guys he's making a lot
of sense
we're not taken aback
we're not taken aback take them the hell
out of here we're not letting you land
your plane crystal-clear now they take
them back you know why now they say we
would love to take them we would love to
take about notice increasingly sweaty
[Applause]
guys how do you not understand what he's
talking about that people have a lottery
in Guatemala and they put a plane up and
then they send them back I mean is it
but how does nobody understand this
policy
they've been great okay in the chat what
percentage of the audience do you think
knows what Trump is talking about right
now like actually knows 2% zero I mean
that's a lie it's just a lie four
billion dollars of military construction
and we've already built over a hundred
miles of wall these are lies by the end
of next year and it's already having we
want technology flawed Spirit is
checking in from Canada says greetings
from Canada love your show rest in peace
to 63 of my countrymen and to all the
others yeah let's just very briefly
break from Trump top Trump's nonsense
just for a second and let's listen to
what Justin Trudeau had to say today
about the what they've now believed was
Iran accidentally unintentionally
downing a Ukrainian airliner and killing
everybody on board have intelligence
from multiple sources oh that's weak
looting our allies and our own
intelligence the evidence indicates that
the plane was shot down by an Iranian
surface-to-air missile this may well
have been unintentional this new
information reinforces the need for a
thorough investigation into this matter
it is now more important than ever that
we know exactly how such a tragedy could
have happened the families of the
victims and all Canadians want answers I
want answers
that means closure transparency
accountability and justice and this
government will not rest until we get
that I think there are many reasons why
Canada has significant issues with Iran
and asked for a number of years but in
this situation it is clear that we are
coming together in the wake of a
terrible tragedy that's befallen
Canadians it is befallen many Iranian
citizens as well really has a way with
words that Trump doesn't so so that's
the latest with the Iran airplane and
we're going to talk about that a little
bit later
thanks to walk not talk for subscribing
with on twitch really appreciate that I
consider this an invitation if you are
watching on twitch right now to renew
your twitch re-up your twitch Prime
subscription let's keep listening to the
mango menace to leave this is your nice
woman to leave
can leave this causes that threats what
he's doing right here they're really in
my opinion at least that's what happened
that's how they got into this
impeachment hoax the leaders of the
party are this AOC
Dileep this AOC and Pelosi meets amici
shakes and Quivers since she's very nice
but you know who the leader of your
party is all of you but the Democrats
are pushing the socialists takeover of
health care
that's very much the unfortunate thing
about the Socialists talking point I
actually have a big segment plan for
tomorrow's show on this the big problem
with the Socialists talking point is
that even people on the left are
confused about what is socialism what is
communism remember social democracy is a
form of capitalism and this this it
continues to be effective because nobody
knows what the hell socialism is
apparently they saw nobody clapping for
that two weeks before the election I'll
let you know the facts this doesn't
matter we're too too far ahead of the
election beauty oh something's happening
here what's going on this guy is being
told something people see what's going
on this guy appeared and is now
admonishing this is something some some
kind of dramas going on the guy has
apparently agreed he's actually asked
him to whatever he was told what do
people think that guy was doing wrong
that caused that to happen
leaps that he's been around for 20 years
in Congress I've seen him I know I'm a
little bit and he's acting like he
actually believes in gum chewing maybe
he was texting was he texting
oh he other racial slur okay that's more
money than we'll ever make we have to
consider his plan strongly now see I'll
tell you what the fake news will do yes
take my last words
it's a great plan we have to consider it
strongly they'll cut everything out in
the front and they'll say Donald Trump
is in favor of Bernie Sanders green New
Deal this is actually pretty funny
I've got a few super chats - okay so let
me let me get caught up because I've
been missing so many things the only one
says via super chat shout out to Shaun
rankling okay good very good shout out
to Shaun rankling Gregory shavers jr.
says Detroit supports Talib Trump and
his lies lol and other super chats there
I'm trying to keep up but they are
flying by over on Twitch hodizzle 77 has
subscribed with twitch prime very much
appreciate that let me also say thanks
to Jakob Scherzer Jakob Scherzer is the
second new member of the evening second
new member of the evening this this
really is I mean these are the rantings
of a madman and I I don't I've never
really watched a full one of these
rallies
I feel like this person's brain is mush
let's see what's going on now
radical Democrats are now the party of
high taxes high crimes open borders late
term abortion socialism and blatant
corruption yes Democrats are going
around asking for socialism and late
term abortions you know what I do think
whoever said that the reason this guy
was spoken to is that he had his head
buried in his phone someone came over to
him and now he's clapping over his head
I think he was told if you want to be on
stage you've got to look more like
you're enjoying this into this insanity
Supreme Court judges think of that one
federal and Court of Appeals judges
think of that thank you president obama
he gave us a hundred and forty two
judges thank you thank you very much
president obama this guy was unsure
about so you have a hundred and forty
choices you got to be kidding i thought
it's a maybe none gave you one but
certainly no more than one they're like
gold they said no sir you have a hundred
and forty-two
producer Pat's texting me saying turn up
Trump's audio it's all the way up guys
I've got it maxed out in 2018 I do want
to tweet something and as we continue
rebuilding our military we have
restarted the legendary army tank
Factory in Lima and we've authorized 441
new Stryker fighting combat vehicles and
453 new Abrams tanks to be built in the
Buckeye State that's a lot of yeah it's
interesting when he looks over to the
side he's his neck it's like it seems
extremely uncomfortable
everything when I came in they want to
close everything so I was
president-elect I think right around
that time and I went to Lyme I went
through the factory where they make
these trucks to plant and they make the
tanks and they make all of these armored
vehicles and I said these people are
amazing you could never close this you
could never reopen it again they've been
doing this for many
decades and this factory was incredible
and I looked at the tanks few other
super Jets final fantasy drafts as unban
Rock Lee he is a david pakman show
member hashtag misunderstanding I don't
know a thing about it
but moderators on YouTube
feel free to unban Rockley if you're
able to otherwise I don't know what the
hell's going on
Anthony Lowe's ago says can you
reiterate why we're watching this you
know that's a good question I wish I
knew the answer because I dropped in and
thought I clicked on Fox News I'm
wondering if this is live it is live can
you poll update people as this unfolds
to make aware there are some very
interesting polls let me pull them up
while we listen to Trump there's some
very interesting polling going on I
looked at how perfect everything was the
turrets the round how perfect it fit
they put it on it would fit like within
1/100 of an inch and I said you're not
going to be able to do this anyplace
else I said and we're gonna be expanding
our military we're gonna be rebuilding
who the hell is gonna make our tanks if
you close it I said keep it open I
actually it was all closed does every
anybody from Lima is that a true story
right it was close they announced it was
closed it was all set to close I said
you can't close this plan and now look
the numbers I just gave you we're making
almost 500 pack
yeah Lima 500 that seems to be the thing
the only one says one more thing Big Ups
liquid Richard and shout out to my boy
Carlito and keep up the great work David
my pleasure
Adam Waddington says once Trump is out
of office could he be prosecuted for
crimes committed while President or
those committed prior what which
surfaced while he was in office yes he
could
Anthony Lozano says as an Ohioan I am
retching over this it's sad you know
when I see the degree to which these
ignorant people are just eating this up
I mean this kid is this a form of child
abused to have this kid at a Magali
is it a form of child abuse I'm just
asking the question Lance Smith Smith
says is free college for children from K
through 12th grade considered socialism
according to these people if
single-payer healthcare socialism
free--free K through 12 is in a sense
also socialism Macola 99 asks if I
watched Trump sounds like Jim Jones part
4 I have not and Shayne babaca says
looks like we avoided war for the time
being yes for the time being let me say
thanks over on twitch oh I have things
popping up I I'm this is weird I have
things happening on Twitch I'm not
familiar with I have like a level to
hype train I don't even know what this
stuff means available rewards I have no
clue what this stuff means but it's very
interesting in any case thanks to you me
for subscribing on Twitch and Ryan FX
for subscribing with prime as well as
Dao Zhi and I already thanked hodizzle
if anybody knows it says I'm at 50% to
level to hype train can someone tell me
what that is I have three minutes with
50% on level 2 hype train on Twitch no
clue what that means disgusting crooked
people with your help we will lift
millions more of our citizens from
welfare to work
citizens dependence to independence and
poverty to prosperity together we will
elect a Republican Congress to create a
safe sane and lawful system of
immigration we will enact trade deals
that result in more products proudly
Scottish he's going into the sure
littering part of the speech oh yeah
Trump is now taking credit for a
decreased cancer death rate and it's
like that's just been the case since we
started treating cancer we are at 100%
level to hypetrain
on twitch I have no clue what it means
and if you're on YouTube you definitely
don't care but we've just gotten to
level two of hype I don't know what it
is if there is a level three let's let's
get to it and no deer and above all we
will never stop fighting for the sacred
values that bind us together as one big
beautiful America it's got to be getting
ready to wrap the constitution of the
monument with the incredible heroes of
law we believe in the dignity of work
and the sanctity of life we believe that
faith and family not government and
bureaucracy are the true American Way
we believe that children should be
taught to love our country honor our
history our this is the slurring part
hopefully he will god bless the United
States of America by the words
[Applause]
we stand on the shoulders of generations
of Ohio Patriots who gave their blood
sweat and tears for this beloved nation
from Cleveland to Cincinnati from Dublin
to Dayton and from Columbus to Toledo
this state is the home of proud families
and farmers and miners and manufacturers
and aviators
and astronauts astronauts hopefully he
says Shirou solemn again that's my
favorite cities where the Wright
brothers and where Annie Oakley got her
gun Ohio is the state that gave us
American legends and American heroes
like Thomas Edison Neil Armstrong and
the great John Glenn Armstrong Madison
2019 says via super chat there are so
many people who claim to be lifelong
Democrats and only started voting
Republican after Obama black became
president
Anthony Lowe's ago says first sign of
old age is no clue unless you're Trump
then no clue means nothing literally so
to speak Caylee is asking his Trump in
Ohio he is indeed Kaley says I'm in Ohio
and living in a poor rural area I'm
surrounded by Trump supporters it blows
my mind
Gregory shavers jr. says I'm sorry David
it must admit it's a guilty pleasure of
mine watching a trump rally 45 is very
entertaining I admit this is extremely
entertaining you know America's going
down in flames sort of way
Caleb Hall says at work in Youngstown
Ohio right now a few trumpets here if
you're bored of Trump's rally go watch
my Trump parody and come back to David's
stream let me say thanks to Kathleen
Parker by the way also for signing up at
join pakman.com one people one family
and one glorious nation under god
america and ladies and gentlemen of Ohio
the best is yet to come
yes it goes together we will make
America wealthy again we will make
America strong again oh boy will make
America proud again we will make America
safe again
it looks like the teeth are coming off
Thank You Toledo thank you
[Applause]
oh dear all right let's turn this down
before I get copyright strikes for the
music so Trump pointing at people this
is actually my favorite moment where is
there a single black person on stage
there they're normally the the the token
black guy over Trump's left shoulder
wasn't there this time a lot of a lot of
Magha hats a lot of red hats is trump
wearing a hat I can't tell ya that's the
move dear God
Wow so that is over and it was it was
absolutely and completely brutal I mean
just brutal attack on the English
language being carried out there okay so
if you're still here if you survive that
we are going to get over to the Iran
Iran plane stuff and I mean there's just
so much craziness going on let's see
here I'm still trying to figure out over
on Twitch what's going on with this
various hype train thing we had a hype
train with nine subs and 944 bits emotes
are being delivered to supporters I have
no idea whatsoever what is going on but
did we not get to hype train level 3 is
that what happened I just wish I
understood what was going on I just
don't know I got a hype a level 2 hype
thing and yeah nobody knows ok well in
any case no idea what's going on I am
NOT a baby boomer by the way I am a
millennial for people who are asking
we're going to what do we want to go we
already did the video of Justin Trudeau
I have a bunch of voicemails that I was
going to play for people as well
Ian Jones says via super chat Ohio also
gave us Trent Reznor but he's a radical
against the system so of course he
doesn't get mentioned oh now Donald
Trump I'm sure has no idea who who Trent
Reznor is also thanks to Kimberly gonna
go for the super chat Rock Lee says why
do yang errs defend yang at all costs on
Medicare for all
yeah Andrew yang at this point I think
we can safely say is not for Medicare
for all he put out the plan and the plan
is is simply not Medicare for all okay
let's go through let's go through the
article about the Iran airplane downing
and I see the super shots continuing to
come in I see that smutty swims
subscribed on Twitch as well as tour
tell rhino and party politics and
Scrivener Vox and techno no go real s
Tilak's realist Felix if it fits leg ik
sin' brett-brett coffee Mikado and Dan
of Earth who says hypetrain is a new
feature if people keep subscribing
donating and cheering the countdown
continues the train if not it starts
over okay very good
Prime Minister Justin Trudeau says
intelligence now indicates the Ukrainian
passenger aircraft that crashed outside
of Tehran on Wednesday killing everyone
on board including a hundred and
thirty-eight people destined for Canada
was shot down by an Iranian missile of
the hundred and seventy-six victims
killed 63 were Canadian citizens and
included entire families academics
students and newlyweds Trudeau said
intelligence and evidence started coming
in overnight suggesting the aircraft was
likely brought down by a surface-to-air
strike but wouldn't offer further
details the prime minister's comments
came after reports of the u.s. said it's
highly likely that an an Iranian that an
Iranian anti-aircraft missile
inadvertently brought down Ukraine
International Airlines flight PS 752
Iranian officials have denied it
scientifically it is impossible that a
missile hit the Ukrainian plane and such
rumors are illogical
according to ali-a beds a day the head
of Iran's Civil Aviation Organization
the crash happened hours after Iran
launched a ballistic missile attack on
Iraqi bases housing US soldiers in
response to the president's targeted
killing of Iranian military come
Kaseem Soleimani when asked if the u.s.
airstrike was in part to blame for the
crash Trudeau said only that Canada
needs a thorough investigation yeah the
idea there is Iran launched missiles
because Trump murdered Soleimani so in
some way Trump can be blamed for the
downing of the airplane
I actually saw some people yesterday
tweeting that they believed the u.s. had
shot down the plane which doesn't make
any sense to me I don't even know where
people got that idea to begin with sort
of sort of odd but we will see what
ultimately comes of this I don't know
that we have more information although
let's listen to the Justin Trudeau
segment once again hopefully the audio
better on this clip there have been
important developments regarding the
potential causes of this deadly crash
developments of which Canadians should
be made aware the news will undoubtedly
come as a further shock to the families
who are already grieving in the face of
this unspeakable tragedy we have
intelligence from multiple sources
including our allies and our own
intelligence the evidence indicates that
the plane was shot down by an Iranian
surface-to-air missile this may well
have been unintentional this new
information reinforces the need for a
thorough investigation into this matter
Canada is working with its allies to
ensure that a thorough and credible
investigation is conducted to determine
the causes of this fatal crash extremely
extremely disturbing and hopefully at
some point we will we will know the full
explanation a few Super chats coming in
Sami Ali Aragon says your thousand
dollar ubi can get you half an ambulance
ride I thought ambulance rides were 750
or maybe that's what you have to pay
insurance
Kevin Chong says keep up the good work
David and folks behind
screen thank you so much Philip knellman
says when is the beta men album getting
dropped oh you you mean children of the
lie with I would be playing drums
Anthony Mellon Fantana would be on bass
Steven Destiny's bunnell ii would be on
keys and we we would hopefully have sam
cedar on vocals but right now we are
still in pre-production let me put it
that way
professor swagga muffin says what's your
favorite political book as of lately I
don't read any modern political books
ever I read older stuff or science books
I'm trying to think what I'm reading
right now I just read the inner game of
tennis I don't play tennis but it was
recommended to me as a business book and
it was pretty good it's a quick read
Kelly Dee says he has only shown that
the United States has an alarming number
of uneducated people make America smart
again yeah that would be a better that
would be a better slogan and Anthony
Lowe's a go says yang is abstracting
that's a non-starter with people that
don't or can't think Rocklea people
arguing with each other in super chat
which is interesting let me say thank
you over on twitch to ghost Killa
oh six for subscribing with twitch prime
very much appreciate that I let's see I
want to talk about some of the new
polling it turns out that Tom Styer has
bought his way I read all the way up to
15% in South Carolina let's take a look
at this political activist Tom Steyer
will be on the Democratic primary stage
Tuesday barely making the cut after
surging and Tunie polls released
Thursday evening former VP Joe Biden is
leading in Nevada at 23 according to Fox
News Burnie at 17 steyr and Warren tied
at 12 Tom Styer at 12 that is absolutely
insane
Pete Budaj edge the former South Bend
Indiana mayor trailing at 6 percent
followed by entrepreneur Andrew yang now
where is the South Carolina ah here it
is
in a separate Fox poll in South Carolina
Biden again led the pack with 36 percent
support Steyr is in second place with 15
percent followed by Sanders 14 and war
ten now I don't think that that is yet
on the South Carolina page oh there it
is it seems to have just been updated
there it is Tom Styer so Biden 36 Bernie
14 Warren 10 Steyr 15 if you look at let
me see if I can find ad spending by
Democratic candidate he is spending just
like an ungodly amount let's take a look
here I guess you can buy your way into
like 15% I guess that's as far as it
goes
steyr who is buying ads steyr this is
not like the cleanest way to look at
this I wanted to look at total spend
explore all ads let's see Tom Styer all
places found 32 ads estimated 78 million
dollars they had that that's got to be
outdated let's see what they have
Bloomberg at here 110 yeah these numbers
are old actually I think it's possible
that Kyle kolinsky tweeted me let's see
I tweeted how does Tom Steyer have 5%
here it is okay Kyle tweeted me this
total TV ad spend by 2020 candidates
Bloomberg 153 million steyr 116 million
10 times the following candidate which
is Bernie Sanders with 11 it's stunning
you can sort of buy your way into the
race apparently and Tom Styer is doing
exactly that so incredible incredible
numbers oh somebody saying that these
numbers are quarterly I thought that
this was total honestly I don't I don't
even really know lieutenant colonel
Allen West Democrat Socialist Party what
on earth is this let's just take a look
at this readings this is Lieutenant
Colonel Allen West the attacks on
President Trump by the Democrat
socialist party now I understand he
media are undermining his presidency and
the future of our country they must be
stopped we need to put an end to these
and show that we support President Trump
all the way through 2020 and it starts
with your phone call we must show that
we have the hey let's call that number
let's see what that pledge your support
for president Trump's re-election in
2020 let's call that number and see what
happens
like - somebody pick up seven seven-30
actually before I do this does anybody
know what will happen and I should have
a plan for what happens if they pick up
it will be a real human you think hmm
I'm just curious where that goes maybe
I'll call and insist on speaking to Alan
West it's against the is working our
economy is booming President Trump is
making good on his promises but the
Progressive Socialist Left are out to
change everything in 2020 the stakes
have never been higher Nancy Pelosi and
the forceful Progressive Socialist in
her party a continuous therefore suit of
impeachment it is tearing this country
apart over the presidency brainwashing I
need you to join me can you even give
money
we urgently need help from supporters
like you can we count on you to make a
contribution to help us support
President Trump and his agenda if you
are willing to make a contribution
please press 1 now let's keep it going
let's see
cause maybe monitored or recorded to
provide you with a quality experience
thank you for calling committee to them
hello thank you for calling committee to
defend the President as you know
Democrats have impeached our president
and committee to defend the president it
is one of President Trump's biggest
allies
we need to keep her Adam here to show
our support for the president now more
than ever
can we count on you to help us with a
gift of 100 or 200 dollars and for a
limited time we can send you at our
Trump 2020 bumper sticker what color is
that bumper sticker young lady because
my car is black is this Allen West I was
calling because Allen West's talked
about the Democrat Socialist Party is
this the right place
yes ma'am absolutely 101 you got
available my friend though but no I mean
the card that bumper sticker it this
comes with the bumper sticker is that
vinyl or rubber
could we find out thank you
$100.00 bumper sticker ah she hung up
okay good I wanted to see how far it
could go like at a certain point you'd
think they would just hang up on me okay
so anyway that was brief diversion she
didn't know what the bumper sticker was
made of which is fine but I didn't even
know I mean it's shocking that Alan West
is still even allowed to endorse anybody
that that's that's really crazy okay let
me get to some of the super Chad's
actually let me thank some people first
so Christi Jones has just signed up at
join pakman.com and is new member number
four of the evening I will open the
phone lines if we get to 15 new members
at join pakman.com we have some
extremely explosive coupon codes at join
pakman.com the the big one is 20 20 now
I recommend yearly at join pakman.com
you hit the signup button and then you
type in 20 20 now that'll drop the $60
membership to 20 20 and if we get 11
more members I will I will open up the
phone lines but in the meantime there
are a few voicemails I wanted to play
oh and super chats if you do have
questions for me feel free to send them
in via super chat and they are scrolling
by so quickly I feel like I'm losing all
of them
Ron says Alan West hasn't been in the
army since 2003 he still calls himself
Lieutenant Colonel what a loser
listen I believe that he's entitled to
that title peasant media says how do you
feel about a Sanders debarred ticket I
am against it I would be fine with
Bernie but I would be much more into
like Bernie Warren for example or you
know almost anything else let's take a
listen to some of the voicemails thanks
to Thailand for subscribing with twitch
Prime as well as Democracy digue very
much appreciated if you're watching over
on Twitch please consider this an
invitation to subscribe with twitch
prime or REO
with twitch prime let's see the
voicemail line is going crazy the phone
lines are not open right now but there
are some voicemails I saw some
interesting callers come up let's see
what is on people's minds
Ruth called in let's see what Ruth had
to say yes hi David um my name is Ruth
Sheridan and I was wondering why we
can't 5150 Trump as well Thank You Santa
yeah Ruth actually got on live with me
and asked me that exact same question
the other day let's see other voicemails
coming in if you like someone's tapping
out a message the way uh intelligence
officers sometimes do I think this is
Morse code oh really okay somebody
better call the police then because that
does not sound good
let's see who else called in ah there's
a five-minute voicemail I'm sort of
scared should I even do I even get
involved in that a five-minute voicemail
I imagine that that's not good the
people want the five-minute voicemail I
mean it could just be a it could be just
dead air people are curious all right
let's see
number one I'm television I mean I watch
different shows and a lot of YouTube
commentators an example Colbert show I'm
curious about where this is gonna go
nobody could stop him
what the hell we have a we have
president
Senate thank okay so just out of
curiosity let's skip ahead to the
4-minute mark and see if it's still
going it is it wasn't really a question
I guess I could have framed it in a
question and said what do you think
about Wow
okay five-minute voicemail that is
unusual we don't get too much of that
let's see a couple of others I always
wonder you know what what is on people's
minds you know living in the United
States
what Trump's on maybe Ottilie sucker
loan well no so I I'm I I want to live
in the United States I want the United
States to be better and then that's why
I say what I think would make the
country better this whole idea of leave
if you don't like it is pretty idiotic
to Iran well I have no interest in
living in a an Islamic theocracy if I
were to move elsewhere I I would Iran is
not where I would go this doesn't make
any sense what do you think of that [ __ ]
let's listen to it in total because this
is this could actually be some kind of
extremely nuanced performance art I want
to listen to this once more tell me in
the chat if you think this is real or if
this is troll sucker loan pick up your
[ __ ] move your ass to Iran so you can
kiss their asses what do you think of
that [ __ ] you're done I've got to
download that I'm gonna have to that one
is gonna have to go on my social media
later we'll call it
I guess hillbilly okay I got it
man that was a good one okay super chats
Val McLin she says please let me know to
whom I should write
so children of the lie the band happens
you have to I would start with Stephen
destiny bonel the second and Anthony
Destiny's Fantana the second those are
the two people right now that we need to
get involved if you have questions or
comments for me and you're watching on
youtube please send me a super chat if
you have a question or comment over on
Twitch feel free to include it with your
twitch Prime subscription Paul Jay Clark
just subscribed with twitch prime Hasib
shaheed has become a member at join
pakman.com as has Caleb Weintraub I like
that it we have someone who I is we have
a huge diversity Weintraub and Shakib I
like that very much and that gets us to
6 of 15 new members this evening there's
some wacky stuff today in the in the
voicemail so let's keep going and see
what else we can find
hey David I was just wondering I've been
arguing as a couple conservatives who
are war hungry
I'd just like to know I'm sure I'd be
missing something but how might you
succinctly let them know that this
conflict with Iraq escalate a Rand
excusing escalating can only lead to bad
things please help me on these bullet
points okay well I I don't think I think
the people you're talking to are
probably beyond reach so I don't know
that I would bother and you deal really
don't need to convince them of that
Trump's the one who needs to be
convinced and it seems like for now he
is not not further escalating let's
listen to a couple others I was just
wondering if you would cover objectively
the general that the United States just
took out of his own history of
atrocities in Syria and Iran yes we have
the issue is that doesn't make an
unauthorized attack by Donald Trump okay
and I think that that's maybe what some
some folks are missing
hello David so I wanted to tell you
about the QRF one I don't know if you
got the message but when you see the
Keurig they activated an outfit like
that in ap Hill and they send them they
have to send them replacements from the
National Guard which is under QF one so
it's more than just thousand troops
there there's another thousand from
National Guard coming in the various
states going to APO
thank you I don't know what on earth
that was about does anybody know what
that had anything to do with I want to
say thanks to James
Montalbano for the super chat as well as
Alexis B Alexis says it's obvious she
wasn't even a trumpet just a call center
worker imagine not being a trumpet and
being forced to say that crap for
minimum wage oh the person that I called
yeah yeah that was really really odd
let's see a couple of other people thank
you got it got it own event ayah says
via super chat hey David cedar has been
Sam cedar has been getting a lot of
attention from vegans lately so I was
wondering what are your thoughts on
veganism also to my fellow Aussies
please attend the climate protest today
can somebody tell me what's going on
with Sam cedar and vegans I'm fine with
people who want to be vegan I have no
problem with that whatsoever I think
they should they should do it I think
it's great but I'm curious what's been
going on with uh with Sam about that
let's take a listen to a couple other
voicemails here wondering if you've ever
heard of the x22 report hosted by a guy
named a
you wondering what your opinion of that
program was what do you think of those
financial collapse conspiracy programs
yeah this is not actually Dave Bergson
this is a guy named Troy York who calls
with different characters here he is
calling with another character I want to
say that you lie that Donald Trump does
not have the authorization to conduct
these airstrikes to kill that Iranian
nut he does have the authorization you
lie
and he didn't okay here is the same guy
Troy York calling in with another one of
his characters hi David Pakman this is
Lincoln Kennedy I forgot to mention two
other okay what's going on that this so
this is a different voicemail line and
people are actively calling it and it
pops off because it's a Google Voice
number so I guess I have to get away
from that okay maybe we will take some
live calls eventually Ryan Garcia just
signed up at join pakman.com thank you
so much Ryan appreciate that that gets
us about halfway there to seven out of
15 okay let's see there were a couple of
other clips that I wanted to show you
that I had queued up let me just pull
them up here clips from today so there
was a moment oh actually this is kind of
funny somebody is somebody clipped let
me see if I can play this somebody
clipped a moment I missed from the rally
of Trump doing some weird evangelical
stuff let's take a listen
evangelicals called some of the greatest
pastors ministers preachers and they
just called today five of the most
respected people and they said things
that were incredible they said there's
never been anything like this in the
church that they can read some of them
have been doing it for 30 40 years they
said we have never seen enthusiasm like
we see for this president and for this
presidency all of us like we have right
really odd very very odd I got a message
oh the other thing I wanted to look at
was I got a message from someone saying
that there is a that there's a glitch in
our best of Trump 2019 video let me see
if I can we can watch that together
Trump worst moment I want to find that
video let's see here
when was this is this the right video I
want to make sure I have it before I
show it to you
nope this is not it see how I can find
this in do in a reasonable amount of
time
I'm curious it's hard to imagine we went
over this video with a fine-tooth comb
and if there's something that shouldn't
be in this video I would be curious
about it I've watched it a whole bunch
of times let me just pull it up in the
meantime and earu sent me a super chat
saying appreciate all your hard work
this super chat is for a comb don't read
this if it's too cheeky no it's fine
Lance Smith majority report published a
22 minute video about the vegan collar
pretty entertaining I laughed ok we'll
look at that in a second let me first
find this end-of-the-year Trump video I
want to see what's going on there in the
meantime thanks to Papa smoke for
subscribing for two months with twitch
Prime as well as Paul Jay Clark really
appreciate that let's see here I've got
to find exactly where this video is we
have so many videos it's hard to find
them December where is this video mean
to the truth about man this is it's like
I'm searching my own video library and
I'm just fumbling president I think it's
called like president Donald Trump
ah here it is okay let's take a look at
this and see I'm not sure what's wrong
with this video I think the video is
fine but let's take a look now go and
take a look at the oranges or the
oranges of the investigation the
beginnings of that investigation look at
my African American over here
I want nothing that's what I want from
you great that's what I said
I want nothing I said it twice god bless
you god bless Israel God bless the
Palestinians and God bless the United
States thank you very much I know words
I had the best words this is a tough
hurricane one of the wettest we've ever
seen from the standpoint of water water
I think is blame on both sides and I
have no doubt about it but you also had
people that were very fine people on
both sides
if Ivanka weren't my daughter perhaps
I'd be dating her
[Music]
it's all good so far
quiet quiet go ahead she's she's asking
a question don't be rude
don't be rude sounds like some coffee no
I'm not gonna give you a quote I'm not
gonna give you a question you are fake
news there is I never attacked him on
his look and believe me this plenty of
subject matter right there that's
actually good I love that we have to
make them perfect he is perfect for
people's thank you thank you thank you
oh not this one this one is too much
there's a key moment here I'm gonna try
to pause right there this is the moment
this is the key moment of this entire
thing but what we want to do is to
replenish the switchin mastery was fun
you can do anything
grab them by the [ __ ] people are
flushing toilets 10 times 15 times as
opposed to once China has total respect
for Donald Trump and for Donald Trump's
very very large upper reign and he
referred to my hands if they're small
something else must be small I guarantee
you there's no problem I guarantee I
don't remember he's gonna like I don't
remember either oh baby that's what I
said we will have no choice but to
totally destroy North Korea Rocketman is
on a suicide mission for himself hi this
video is seems great what would this
this just seems perfect producer Pat did
a great job people who to people who
wrote and said there's a problem with
this video I'm not seeing any problem
the problem is 227 people disliked it
when it should be a hundred percent
likes best not make any more threats to
the United States they will be met with
fire and fury like the world has never
seen
oh dear but we have some bad umbrage
here and we're gonna get them out oh
this is this the toilet paper one no
this is just a hair flip flopped one oh
there's the toilet paper that's a Toby I
think that this video is to say it the
way Donald Trump described his phone
call with Ukraine I think this is a
perfect video I think this is a perfect
video someone comes out and grabs that
excellent absolutely excellent excellent
video $300 super chat over on YouTube
from Anthony Lowe's a go thank you very
much Anthony Lowe's a go with a $300
super chat says I suspect Trump will win
if we don't go yang 2020 I suspect
Democrats will simply miss every
opportunity to move forward we really
need a universally neutral candidate
that just wants to fix problems and is
not indebted to lobbyists or
corporations yang 2020 look it up people
listen I've not seen the data that backs
that up I've not seen the data that says
only Andrew yang can win oh people want
to link to this video yeah I'll put it
in the chat on both YouTube and twitch
spread that one around folks it's a
doozy okay let's do let's do the Sam
cedar vegan caller video because a lot
of people are talking about that 22
minutes from three days ago I don't know
if I can do this but let's listen to a
little bit of it oh so let me mention
I'm seeing people saying before we do
this there are people saying the coupon
code is not working the coupon code is
working so strongly that I can't even
tell you we are at 7 of 15 new members
if we get to 15 I'll open up the phone
lines the coupon code 20 20 now works it
works on every single one of these
memberships okay you hit the sign up
button 20 20 now boom $6 becomes two
dollars and two cents it's a beautiful
thing if you do yearly I recommend
yearly same thing coupon code 20 20 now
saves you 67% drops it to 20 20 okay so
the
person was Ryan Garcia let's look at a
little bit of this Sam I'm not gonna do
the whole thing I know a lot of people
in the audience don't aren't aren't
interested in you know veganism stuff
but since it was brought up by a couple
of people let's just see what the
discussion is and we'll do it like on
slightly faster speed Wow a lot of
people on the phones here oh boy oh boy
oh boy let's take this one come from a
two eight nine area code who's this
where you come from
hey I think it is are you you fantastic
all right I am me I'm pretty sure I
think so it's a pathology right how are
you doing I'm doing well how are you I'm
fantastic I'm actually calling from
Canada from Guelph
um what I wanted to ask you about was
actually animal ethics um today's a good
few people in this like your good friend
stefan molyneux hmm you know and and
some other people and more like ear side
Destinee vash people like that i wanted
to ask about your stance err I mean if
that's okay
by the way I have no clue what Sam's
going to say but when I see Sam in Vegas
twice a year
he is the guy with absolutely no dietary
restrictions ever like Sam Sam will try
anything you put in front of the animals
that are being farmed right now with
humans you deem that situation to be
morally unacceptable right if human
beings were being raised for food yes we
just replace all the animals currently
being farmed with humans right yes I
think I would somehow find that
unacceptable okay now if we are doing it
with animals though you take it to be
accessible um III think that's where our
society's at I mean I personally
personally try and avoid factory farmed
animals but you know and I I see it as
problematic I don't see it as a top
priority in terms of like at least what
I want to do professionally in terms of
politics um I could ask it like this do
you think that it's morally acceptable
to buy those products um do I think it's
morally acceptable I mean
I don't know I mean I you know for me
personally I don't do it wait but you're
not you're not vegan you do buy the
products right well when I eat meat I
try and do non factory farm to meet okay
but you still buy the meat oh yeah I
still I'm not I am not vegan right okay
so but the point the point here would be
if it's animals you wouldn't say it's
okay to buy you know ninety or humans
you wouldn't say it's okay to buy you
know mostly free-range human the tiny
bit of facts absolutely right that's
correct I do not believe that when she
work I I have less of a problem with
eating animals than I do with humans
okay so this is where I'm going with it
right in the animal context it's okay to
you know buy the family farmed animals
and occasionally the factory farmed
animals but in the human context neither
are okay right I'm wondering what is it
for me right yeah oh yeah I'm just
wondering what is it that's true of the
animals that if true of the humans would
cause you to say that that is acceptable
well the the humans have human DNA right
and the animals don't I think I mean I
think for me honestly it's watching
animals kill each other in the wild and
there not being any sort of
determination that it's wrong by the
animals I mean in all honesty like I
mean I don't I don't feel you know like
I don't I don't have a sort of like
clear strongly held beliefs in these
areas but I mean just if you're asking
in passing I would say the thing that I
think allows me to not prioritize it
although I think that there is a there's
certainly a decent argument to
prioritize it I think the thing for me
is is watching animals in the wild kill
each other and them not appearing to to
organize around it and determine that
it's wrong okay so you would say that
the thing that makes the moral
difference that makes it such that you'd
say you're using moral difference i I
mean I you know I don't I don't know if
I think it's moral or immoral I don't
I'm not really thinking about it in
those terms but in the human cases often
human gauge you say it the moral though
right well we've certainly decided as a
society that killing is not Afghan
Society okay well I live in society and
I live in a society where we've decided
that it's wrong and I
no if I didn't live in a society and I
was you know living on the land and you
know like I don't let me put it this way
if we have some type of you know nuclear
event or we're living in some type of
you know so-called post-apocalyptic
world I don't know that I would think it
would be wrong to kill humans right but
what I asked was what makes the moral
difference between the two situation and
I'm telling you I'm sorry I just don't
I'm not like I don't think about it in
terms of morality I'm giving you the
most honest answer I can't you think
it's don't you think it's morally wrong
in the human context that sounds like
thinking in terms in reality if you pay
you don't think it's morally wrong to
you know just Holocaust people then okay
but I take it that's not your view well
look you want me to keep saying moral
because that's what's helpful for your
argument and I don't know if you weren't
there I could hear you do you want me to
keep story moral because that's the way
that you look at it I'm telling you
that then we can talk about that do you
not look at killing humans as a moral
issue the Holocaust of humans for food
that wouldn't be a moral issue in your
view I just think that it's I mean I I
don't know that it's like III don't know
the weird thing about continuing to talk
about humans eating humans is like that
that's cannibalism that's a different
issue altogether isn't it like I we I
don't even I mean I I'm having a hard
time falling is that moral issue or not
what is what is morality explain that to
me
what's your vision - mirela I'm okay I'm
a subjectivist I mean I just take
morality to be a better graphic this
okay it is against my preference it is
against my preference let me put this
way I'm gonna use your term it is
against my preference that we kill human
beings because and I'll tell you why
because I think it's the only way for
humans to survive is to not kill each
other and I think it is you know at the
very least it is the start of being
nicer to everything if we don't kill
human beings because we relate to human
beings the most so okay that's my
preference as to why when is not it is
not to my you know like a high priority
of my preference it would be my
preference I know what you're asking and
I'm telling you that my answer does not
fit into lieu narrow confines of what
you want
I'm giving you my honest answer you
asked me why it's not as important to me
that animals they don't know what the
people eat and massive you said more you
just described moral as preference now
I'm telling you good I can't tell who's
more triggered what's going on hold on
your phone is everything up good yeah I
ask you what's true of the ones that get
true of the other would cause you to
have the same evaluation I've told you
to clear up the morality thing usually
human being and morality at all because
in my view it's like if you're not using
it in the case of Holocaust Inhumans
then you know all right can't see where
else you possibly use it right you just
not use moral language I mean I'm happy
to move to subjective is kind of
preference language that's fine actually
the language I tend not sometimes moral
moral language that is correct the show
you know not to do shirts not to do a
big philosophy derail but when you're
some kind of subjective it but you think
I don't know what that means so I can't
answer that question okay well I'll just
ask with the word preference right so it
is in line with your preference for us
to support the Holocaust of animals to
some degree family farming with some
degree of factory farming but it is not
in line with your preference to support
the Holocaust of humans you know
something that factory farming some
amount of family farming of humans
so I'm asking correct what is it the
true of animals that if true of humans
would cause you to say yes is in line
without having any human DNA human
beings went around killing each other
without deciding on societies that it's
wrong I might my my ideas would change
okay I understand your answer now the
response to that answer would be debate
okay so yes everyone else was just
killing each other do you right now take
the view that in that world it would
just be ethical the Holocaust people and
eat them to Holocaust people and if
everybody was saying talking about from
your views going answer from their view
I'm asking if you would evaluate it to
be appropriate so long as maybe maybe
it's a hard it's a hard hypothetical
from you put myself into right now but
maybe I'm open to it let's put it that
way
well okay wait so just to be clear your
view and I don't I don't want any
equivocation or not asking if you're
correct well I'm sorry okay on your
hypothetical about everybody going
around killing your code ear okay let's
pause there do people want me to keep
going with this or how we sort of heard
enough
of it let me know meanwhile I want to
thank a few new members Kevin Chong has
just signed up with a brutally huge $240
a year membership thanks Kevin very much
appreciate it
Nicolas Rivera has signed up Gilligan
Weston is a new member as is Shannon
wills and Heather Alpert thank you so
much Heather as well as T batty that is
1 2 3 4 5 6 that is 6 more which gets us
to 13 out of 15 just two more two more
new members and we will open up the
phone lines a few people say keep going
with this clip I'll do a couple more
minutes let me do a couple super chats
though Bret and Webber says from Canada
lived in Seattle in 2000 just outside of
Phoenix from o7 to 2011 lots of Trump
supporters here but most of us despise
him and unfortunately American is
laughed at here due to him yeah a lot of
Trump is either deny that we're being
laughed at worldwide or say that they
don't care who laughs at us it's like
okay well which of which one is it over
on twitch let's see
fried sickle subscribes for five months
with twitch Prime Nieto DeVito subscribe
CPT Rama subscribes with prime I see
people saying that there are messages
associated with the cheers but I'm not
seeing those let me see if I can pull
those up I didn't realize people were
sending messages with the with the
cheers let me see if I can access that
where is it huh oh here we go
twitch
all right I'm pulling those up I don't
want to ignore people events let's take
a look here okay oh I see okay let's see
have I heard of Allan Lichtman I've
interviewed him on the show twice is it
moral to eat your boogers
I see no moral issue with it just say it
David cannibalism is not kosher I I
don't know the rules of kosher to be
honest meat is the new tobacco certainly
you know how to pronounce cedar okay
that's all those are all the messages
that I'm seeing all right let's look
back let's look at a little more of this
well I'm telling you I'm going to
reserve my right to equivocate because I
don't know I need to know more details
about this post-apocalyptic world that
you're talking about that I'm also able
to organize a factory farm what
everybody's going around killing each
other okay what do you think the
equivocation is that I'm referring to I
don't know you're just saying I don't
want to do a pelvic 8 I'm telling you
you're kind of trying to deal with humor
though because I've got you in a bit of
a corner there's nothing better than
someone's saying they're winning the
debate right I'm not asking what your
preference inside of the hypothetical
would be I'm asking for you right now in
your perspective to evaluate
hypothetical I'll walk you through the
reason you gave right so we cooked the
two situations but human and animal howl
dude I don't need a hypothetical I just
told you why I have less of an issue
with eating animals and I do humans you
said different you say the thing that
makes the difference to me is that I
watch animals kill each other right so
what I'm doing is I'm applying that in
the human context and I think if you
then evaluated yes so if they know what
the contradiction yes I answer your
question I answered it when you yell I
actually can't hear it maxes out my
phone please
Oh in which case I'm going to turn up my
volume because I'm getting a little
frustrated I'm gonna say this quietly
okay we lived in a world where there
were no societal norms about killing
other human beings and eating them okay
which I have yep noticed in the animal
kingdom including like my you have what
in the animal 30 thought you have what
in the animal just get a sound bit that
means isolate and then post some okay
clear it sounds like you're getting fed
up with the call so I don't want to take
up all your time that you want to go
what is the quest of the animal
Holocaust that get through the human
Holocaust because it's be morally
justified on your view you said the
factor that would make that difference
right and morality can just cash out and
preferences that's fine you said the
factor that would make the difference is
if the other members of the species are
killing each other and not caring about
it now I put the reductio view each
other other humans are killing and
eating each other and don't care about
it would you actually evaluate it to be
ethical to Holocaust people and your
answer to that is yes or no I'm going to
thank you I appreciate that we're almost
done guys is it ethical
I think it's decided in line with your
preferences if setting if society has
found it to be non problematic to go
around and kill human beings and eat
them then would I perceive it as
problematic that we were doing it in a
factory style as opposed to just random
killing but keep in mind I'm asking you
right now I'm not asking is
hypothetically you and the hypothetical
would have determined preferences their
different freedom this is one of the
worst vegan debaters that maybe I've
ever seen but also Sam is just kind of
kicked allowing it to keep going I think
we're done Lynn Smith says via super
chat should Sam just admit that he's a
speciesist
Matt Dillahunty does this when vegans
are after him oh let me let me say
Dillahunty vegan I just want to see what
that's like
oh these are like oh my god two hours
we're not gonna do that
Matt Dillahunty versus a vegan gains
atheist experience call okay yeah this
is probably - way more than we want to
do but yeah let's let's just but let's
let's say that we're done for the time
being okay welcome - oh wait a second
hold on no - welcome to no one we still
are we still are two members away from
opening the phone
let's see that I miss of Oh
Oh oz is calling in even though the
phone lines aren't open I'll see what he
said is this my stream in the background
[Music]
man I hope oz isn't off the wagon or on
the wagon or whatever we've had we've
had a number of calls with Oz and they'd
sometimes they go okay and you know we
were worried about Oz let me put it that
way
Rock Lee says animals can't really
communicate across species well I don't
know what that means I really have no
idea what that means whatsoever weird
yeah I don't know I don't know what
that's about that's strange
okay let me pull up the other things I
had for you guys today let me see here
there was a particular Hannity clip that
I wanted to play I'm just looking for it
now let me see here where was this oh
yeah here's the clip okay this is a clip
someone sent me of Sean Hannity
suggesting creating poverty in Iran I
haven't watched it but people have said
it's weird
they have three major four fineries in
in Iran senator three I would imagine
those refineries blew up one day they
got themselves a hell of a domestic
problem because that's going to result
in major poverty for the people of Iran
and if they want regime change that's up
to them maybe we can help them with arms
and help them you know in some ways but
we're not sending our sons and daughters
there with the quad so this was the clip
of Hannity much like Tucker kind of
saying yeah we don't want boots on the
ground
he doesn't want boots on the ground okay
I mean listen if whatever whatever keeps
us out of a war there is good
super chat from hala sheen who says what
are your thoughts on your state's legal
weed do you smoke I don't smoke anything
I think you know putting smoke in your
lungs is bad for you so
do it but I mean listen Massachusetts
was the first to legalize gay marriage
it was a complete non-event in terms of
you know whatever people were worried
about it was great for people who were
then able to get married but it was fine
pots been legalized it's fine
everything's totally completely fine
NP says via super chat what is it with
these cocky young men always starting
these weak debates with no long term
plan I guess they think if it worked
once it will work again let me actually
show you something really funny well I I
have to now find both clips Packman
kansas troll resurfaces let me see here
nazi phobia anti-semitic racist kansas
troll oh here it is okay so there's this
guy named that I know is the Kansas
troll who has actually called Sam cedar
as well so let me see Sam cedar it's
like stupid young man or something like
that here we go okay so check this out
this this is like a multi-layered thing
and in a second we will let me see here
Steve Arnett has signed up at join
pakman.com so that does get us to 14 of
15 new members so if one more person
signs up we'll open the phone lines
listen to this guy who called into Sam's
show in 2017 all right last call today
called from a 785 area code who's this
oh yeah this is John Connor from Los
Angeles California
what's on your mind John I wanted to
make a comment about the charter schools
there anything that charter schools are
failures is actually because the same
reason why urban public schools are a
failure zone it's entirely comprised of
low IQ like City dwelling minorities you
know it's common knowledge that blacks
score lower on standardized testing
which blacks actually score on the same
level for whites and okay so anyways
super super racist guy this is the keys
not John Connor from from Los Angeles
this is a guy who's been calling me for
years and years and years and years that
we call this guy the Kansas troll and he
actually got me live on the phone once
and it was so anticlimactic take a look
at that scholar of course six one seven
eight three zero forty seven fifty is
the number we'll go to our next caller
from the 785 area code caller what's
your name where you calling from and
what can we do for you today oh yes hi
my name is Abby I'm calling from Kansas
City Missouri so this now he says his
name is avi so this is a pet apparently
his Jewish character before he was John
Connor an Irish Californian now he is
avi from Kansas City Missouri same the
same kid okay here we go hey is this the
Kansas troll now I immediately I forgot
about this because of 785 I immediately
wondered if it was the Kansas troll and
the kid I think just casually says it's
not okay oh I'm sorry okay yeah yeah
yeah but of course that's a lie it's
actually the Kansas true enough good
okay so I just wanted to say the waiting
music was really horrible um but I was
wondering about your copy I saw your
selling coffee now in coffee mugs we're
not selling coffee mugs but we are
selling coffee okay so um what kind but
what exactly type of blend is this
coffee because I saw Alex Jones is also
selling a coffee it's called Patriot
blend and I was wondering how that's
going to be different with your coffee
our coffee just has nothing to do with
Alex Jones's coffee at all will you be
coming out with the liberal progressive
[ __ ] pansy super female blend with
added fluoride this is the kansas troll
I knew it when I saw the number I knew
that it was I'm fine keeping him on by
the way no we're not gonna have a [ __ ]
fluoride blend no okay well thanks for
taking my call it was a real honor to
talk to you pac-man alright well thank
you so much really appreciate it what a
waste of time that's the Kansas so
anyway that that was the guy and
it's the same guy that that called in
and argued with Sam that time and it's a
little a little bit of a bat back story
on some of the different trolls there's
also the San Antonio troll which is a
different person altogether anyway
thanks for the super chat which reminded
me of this a sandbox er thank you for
subscribing for five months on Twitch
prime thanks also to East mo 87 although
I think I thanked East mo 87 already let
me say o of some super chats albariño
gold says bottom line eating meat is
incredibly damaging to the ecosystem I
appreciate you David but talk about
Jared Kushner sometime okay well we talk
about Jared before he's an interesting
character
uh let's see pant man says did you see
destiny debate ask yourself after I
don't know what ask yourself is I don't
know what that is so I definitely didn't
see it
Rock Lee says sam cedars argument about
animal animals as a whole not deciding
murder is wrong lazily ignores the fact
that different species can't communicate
like interspecies animals that is very
true humans are very different than
other species for sure
the vegan from the video is ask yourself
okay yeah I just don't know who any of
these people are aster so ask yourself
is the caller on the Sam cedar clip oh I
see ask yourself is the vegan who
debated debated me when did I debate
someone named to ask yourself I debated
someone named ask yourself I have no
recollection of that can someone tell me
when I divided abated this person I have
no recollection of that I guess nobody
knows okay weird
I debated him right now okay very weird
I don't know what the hell people are
talking about but it's it's very very
strange all right so we we we dealt with
that and let me see if there's any other
Kansas troll thing that comes up now I
guess so let me see one more Kansas
troll pac-man let me see if any others
come up look at all these Kansas
trophies let's look at an old one just
so I don't remember it oh here's a four
year old video Kansas troll unhinged
let's see we have a voicemail number the
number is two one nine two david p we
have a voice mail today from the kansas
troll and the kansas troll lewis is
completely unhinged
in today's voicemail the topic is the
Kansas in the Charleston South Carolina
rather Church shooting involving the
admitted shooter Dylann roof here is the
Kansas troll very upset you know I will
not even become angry with his voice now
it's just I have become so overwhelmed
with idiocracy from the David Pakman
show but there's actually no reason for
it I will not allow it to be get me to
the level of anger but the fact that you
think that this Dylann storm roof guy
killed black people simply because they
were black that's why he went into the
church you are an absolute [ __ ]
he kills black people in that church
because he was a mentally unstable
individual but his real reasoning behind
it which actually has some truth is the
fact that black people commit an
enormous amount of crime against white
compared to their per capita ignore
elation that's something that the David
Pakman show will never discuss just
something that the liberal media will
never discuss because you know when you
say anything bad about black you're a
racist
anyway this this guy very very obsessed
with race okay let me say thanks to
Trevor Martindale who has signed up and
his new member number 15 so let's open
the phone lines at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 it
is getting late so we'll take a few
quick
phone calls I will also keep reading
super chats as they come in and also
twitch messages but let's take a few
calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0
4750 thank you for calling in to the
David Pakman show please do not use
speakerphone have your question ready
and listen for David to call out your
area code 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 is the
number if you want to talk to me this is
the opportunity we'll take a few calls
it is getting to be past my bedtime
though it is 4 a.m. here in Poland let's
see here let's go right to our caller
from the two one two area code who's
calling today from two one two hey can
you hear me yes I can
alright I get a more of a personal
dilemma but first off let me start out
by saying I support Bernie Sanders and
the Medicare for all bill their plan
rather that he's trying to push through
and has been trying to push through my
personal dilemma is and I believe I
called about a month ago and we
discussed homelessness do you remember
that you know I don't I apologize not
that's fine so I am currently homeless I
am on a suboxone program you need to
deal with substance use issues and I've
been a working-class adult my whole life
up until the age of about 27 I'm 28 now
and my issue is I'm on Medicaid right
now and you know it's it's it's kind of
hard making that transition especially
when you're on a medicine that you need
for quality of life into the workforce
when that will throw the health
insurance you have completely out of
whack and that's my biggest fear so you
know it's just a tough situation got any
thoughts on that you're saying that
right now you're getting the care you
need through Medicaid you're homeless
and that you qualify for Medicaid
but you're concerned that if you get a
job then you will lose Medicaid and
possibly lose the care that you
currently have that's right and if I get
off the medicine that I'm on it would
defeat the purpose of getting a job
because I would be in hospital care for
withdrawals and I would lose the job and
that would set me right back to where I
was three years ago so let me ask I mean
if you if you were to get a job that
doesn't offer health care or whose
income is low enough you you would still
be able to keep Medicaid if you get a
job that provides health care then
wouldn't you be able to get the care you
need through that job well that's the
problem a lot of you talk about the gig
economy a lot and that's a big issue no
matter where you go and I've had a lot
of those jobs and typically with those
jobs you have to work for 90 days before
they would sign you up for their health
insurance package during that time
wouldn't you be able to keep the
Medicaid know your income would offset
the Medicaid so let me so hold on a sec
let me I want to make sure that I don't
say I don't suggest you do anything
illegal here but what would medicate
immediately know that you have a job if
you understand what I'm saying typically
there's you know some period of time
before they ask you to reauthorize you
know riri qualify yes I've been in this
situation before and I've lost a job
unfortunately due to that situation
nerve I mean at least well I'm in New
York City right now so there are 70,000
homeless people you know figure out the
numbers what is it seventy-five eighty
percent have substance use or mental
health issues and if they lose their
health insurance because they get a job
and want to better their life I mean it
just doesn't work out so we have this
enormous problem I suppose this could be
a talking point if implemented correctly
but we have this enormous problem where
there are people in cities big cities
rural areas who are going through
problems they need health insurer
to deal with those issues and if you
know they want to do the right thing
which is what conservatives tell them
they need to do is pull themselves up by
their bootstraps it completely defeats
the purpose of what they're doing I mean
it'll set them back so it's just it's a
multi-faceted issue I understand health
care isn't simple but it's it's a
problem that's why you know I've really
hoped Bernie wins man I really do I just
you know I can't see so many more years
of having to deal with this problem I I
feel for you I don't have the answer I
wish I did but a completely different
system seems to be what what we actually
need that's correct
you know it's just health insurance is
complex it needs to be simplified no one
make a lot of people's lives easier
appreciate you hear me out David all
right thank you so much I appreciate the
phone call I hope to hear from you again
people in the chat asking if I want to
go do a vegan debate on some someone
else's channel no I'm taking phone calls
right now and then I'm all I'm all good
let's go next to a former Trump
supporter Phil from the three four seven
Phil what's going on with you okay man
is that my official title from now on
former Trump is how I have you in the
system Phil former Trump right yeah I
have you been following any of the
polling from like aggregate sites like
538 recently I'm stuff like and I'm
Pietschmann support in favorability for
try yeah I mean I've been looking at a
bunch of different stuff on 538 I don't
have that in front of me but I'll see if
I can find it so uh have you noticed
what the recent kind of jump in support
for removing and impeaching Trump I
haven't most Republicans do American
support range from take a look here you
know what I have it in front of me and I
see I see 9.8 Republican support and
it's basically the same it's actually at
one point it looks like it was 15 so no
I'm not seeing that on 538 hmm
interesting I'm seeing a jump from
eleven point three percent to 15 to
about fourteen point nine
right now I'm on projects that
fivethirtyeight.com slash impeachment -
polls and it has Republican support at
9.8 percent yeah I'm on the same site
interesting but yeah I was gonna ask you
about that because it seems pretty
significant in like recent kind of days
but I guess yeah I just I'm just seeing
different data
yeah I'm just seeing different different
global weird yeah but you know in case
what I'm seeing is actually like maybe
you're not updated or something but what
uh oh yeah oh you know what now what now
I'm actually seeing so I do see let's
see so I was looking at support for
removing Trump that has not gone up
support for impeachment has gone up by
Republicans but it's gone up after he
was impeached and they don't support
removing him so I don't know that I
would read much into it I think it's
it's hard I don't I don't think it's
particularly meaningful what what what
do you think explains that jump even
though you know it's not necessarily
just for removal I think it's trolling I
think it's that the the guys already
impeached so now they're saying yeah we
support impeachment I think it's totally
meaningless I mean I wouldn't read
anything into it would you say the same
thing for independent no maybe
independence it's more meaningful I mean
listen you know the guy's been impeached
Republicans are not increasing their
support for removing him but support for
an impeachment that has already happened
has gone up a little bit it could be
cognitive dissonance right could be
trolling I don't know okay I was I was
kind of thinking it was more to do with
the Iran stuff but maybe it's really
nothing maybe you would think support
for removing him would also go up in
that case right yeah okay that's weird
all right Phil thank you very much great
to hear from you hope to hear from you
again let me say thanks to wax matches
for subscribing for two months with
twitch Prime and if you are watching on
twitch P please feel free to revive or
start a twitch Prime subscription I
continue to see people telling me that a
vegan collar from Sam cedar wants to
talk to me I'm all good
I'm just I'm just
interested I'm just not interested let's
go to our next caller let's go - lets go
- Eileen from the 8:45 area code I think
according to this Eileen it's been like
10 months since we last heard from you
is that right it's about right I know I
and I and I have the freaking I didn't
listen expecting you to answer
where are you by the way Eileen are you
out at a sporting event oh is that that
sounds like Trump's voice that you're
listening to yeah I know okay so I'm
sorry it's a request please David do an
entire show if you can about the trunk
children hmm which ones especially
Ivanka and Jared especially Jared I mean
it's scary the access that they have
they don't have security clearances and
Jared is in the frickin Middle East
mm-hmm
Jared's not one of his kids but I know
what you mean really you this is David
yeah okay
so just sometimes you think it was
fooling me well I'm watching you live
and you don't seem to be answering me
well there must be some kind of a delay
it's definitely a delay because now
you're okay now I see you laughing I'm
sorry so just it was just a request
honey got it okay thank you so much no
we will continue to cut mean it's it's
atrocious that they are unelected they
were supposedly not going to be involved
and they're involved and if it was
Chelsea Clinton Republicans would be
going absolutely crazy I mean you're
completely right exactly yeah thanks
David
Eileen always a pleasure always a
pleasure Eileen hope to hear from you
again thank you so much for watching
let's see who else we can briefly pick
up on here let's try the 931 area code
who's calling today from 931 hey David
slogans in Tennessee again how are you
man hey Logan
hey um so real quick just touch on what
miss Eileen was just talking about
nobody has anything to say what about
what you know the Trump kids but you
know they're all pounding the table
about you know hard Biden all that right
excuse me
so my question that I was calling about
was so if Trump God God willing loses
the election coming up what breathing
emphasis does Iran or any of our you
know Habra cherries have to trust that
will come to the table in good faith
knowing that in four to eight years
later we've got president found Ted Cruz
or whatever you know yeah that there
they have no reason to believe it tries
to any deal that we found you know
commit to knowing that somebody could
immediately just back out you know
absolutely everything I've been pointing
this out for some time if we once
countries don't have any reason to
believe that we will stick to agreements
that we get into under one president if
the next president doesn't like it
why would they negotiate with us why
would they work with us every day would
not this is exactly the problem and I
thought that is one of the biggest
concerns with this policy right and
especially when it goes like much deeper
than just Trump you know like Michael
Brooks was talking about how we had Iran
under like a stranglehold economically
for years we finally come to the table
sign the agreement and then just wanted
to be torn up and thrown in their face
and then we are now given that like
honey I personally believe it we're very
much the aggressors and all this given
that you know in the history going back
to when we overthrew their
democratically like together fifties and
established the Shah just give it a
hands in the room so I don't there's no
question that it's been that it's been a
long history but I also think it's you
know there are people who are pointing
through the history to basically absolve
Trump of any responsibility or agency in
his decision-making which we don't want
to allow right yeah just be clear that
not my stance what yes if anything he's
exacerbating like you know that kind of
precedents no doubt no doubt about it
agree with you 100%
okay I appreciate it last thing
are you still drumming I saw all of your
previous live feeds we're here what you
got the electronic it man yes I'm still
I'm actively I'm playing drums I'm not
I'm not currently in a band but we're
trying to get the you know the
progressive all-star band together the
children of the lie and do an original
song so we're still working on that
I will absolutely pick up your first
thing whenever you alright thank you so
much great to talk to you appreciate it
thank you so much okay that's gonna do
it for me if you're watching over on
Twitch we are going to raid Hasan just
for kicks so I hope you'll join me in
raiding Hasan if you're over on YouTube
this this doesn't even exist over on
YouTube so thanks to everybody who
joined me I will stream again I don't
know when but it'll happen and I will be
presumably doing live coverage of next
week's debate live on Twitch we will see